hello everyone its Perry here with
another exclusive Collider interview a
very exciting one right now because we
have the whole ensemble or almost the
whole ensemble of Fantasy Island here
I'll give a quick shout out to Maggie Q
who's not here she's so good in this
movie but Lucy I wanted to start with
you because obviously returning it to
work with Jeff Jill and Chris on this
movie so truth or dare and this very
different movies but are there any kind
of things that stay consistent from one
to the other that make you think this
trio makes a really fun appealing horror
movie I mean they just know how to write
they know how to create really great
characters and what I loved about
fantasy island is that it was completely
different from my character in truth or
dare happy um
and I mean they're just great they know
how to write a really entertainment
entertaining movie with a lot of twists
and turns and I'm just glad that they
had me back this is great so Jeff was
just won't like this or is it the Mike
you yeah so Jeff was telling me that he
likes to cast the actor not the
character so for each of you you could
pass around the mic I'm curious what
part of you did you bring to your
character that maybe wasn't on the page
when he first read the script while
piggyback off the first question what
was cool about working with those three
is and I didn't expect it too much
because we talked about it a little bit
you know when I was hired is how
collaborative these guys are and how
much they weigh like you know you you
want to bring in your best ideas and
then the fact that they were you know I
was a they were able to use maybe a
couple of them you know makes you just
feel like you're part of the process
part of it and for me I had just done
narcos Mexico and and I spent a lot of
time in Mexico and I we talked a lot
about the character of mr. vork and you
know he how iconic Ricardo I always mess
mess up his name Montalban did I mess it
up again cool
no but he was he was so iconic in this
so I kind of just played a person from
like Mexico City because there's like
these intellectuals in Mexico City and
like alejandro
one of them and I'll phone staccato
unlike when when you hear them talking
with each other it's like they're it's
like they're speaking another language
so but they have a very distinct way of
speaking and we definitely tried to
accomplish that and I think Jeff and and
the writers definitely did want to pass
that around anybody else want to chime
in on that one yeah you know it was
interesting because I think the I've
never been to Fiji and I just the
environment it what you're watching is
real you know like with my character and
running through the trees and us and
waterfalls and that enhances also what
your character turns out to be as well
because you're really in it you're
forced to be in it you're actually not
imagining it and so much you know like
when you're working in studios you kind
of recreate that vibe but it was
happening real time in that situation
and that always enhances like especially
with thrillers and horrors that enhances
the grit because the dirts real you know
like we're really in it you know but
yeah I think um I think that it just I I
think with with writing like this that's
just fun and has some sort of like
flexibility in terms of you know
creating those like horror moments with
with one another it's fun because I was
surprised along the way with you know
the moments that you have with actors
especially when you're in it and on a
cruise ship and living together and just
kind of being able to bond that informs
that helped me inform you know who's
Sloane was throughout the throughout the
way and to piggyback off what Portia was
saying about how about it being so real
and so my character because that's what
you song I'm piggy backing up the piggy
back okay okay and so to choose say how
real it wasn't stuff and I will say you
know for for our stuff we play we play
brothers and we love to party have a
great time and that was real and also
the the hundreds of models that are in
our fantasy in the movie real yeah very
real and
and we really had a good time it was I
mean it was a very tough acting job for
us that I where to pretend like we like
acting and like partying and you know
pretend like we liked the models and
stuff and like we like to hang on Fiji
it was tough a lot of mental preparation
went into you know just being in Fiji
for two months but I stink at the end of
the day all the hard work you put in
shows up on the screen that's right
Jimmy don't sell yourself short because
the other thing I wanted to ask you is
obviously we don't want to give any
spoilers away but I thought I pegged
your character and exactly who he was
the second I met him and there are more
layers than I ever could have imagined
to that character thank you very much
and and I think you know piggybacking
what our Pena was saying from the very
beginning it's always to be a very
collaborative effort like the first day
I met with Jeff we sat down a coffee
shop in that and he pitched me all these
layers and turns and stuff and I was
like I was so into it and then
piggybacking on what Portia was saying
once you get to Fiji the environment
really sucks you in and you just get
into the character and you just play
moment to moment what really needed to
rely on each other as cast mates and as
the characters so it ended up like to me
feeling very real every moment and you
know we just focused on playing the
moments and yeah yeah it was great it
was great working with this guy you know
awesome you're not getting out of this
one
what is uh what did you get to bring to
your character that might not have been
on the page piggybacking off anything
I have original thoughts anything said
so far I would like to say that the the
process that we were allowed to have
before we started shooting was essential
to our work because we're all we're in
Fantasy Island right and were it's all
supposed to be fun and everybody's kind
of wondering how is this going to turn
out and a lot of uneasiness and that
feeling was
was present because none of us thought I
don't think had been to Fiji before and
wondering what it's going to be like to
be shooting out in the jungle and there
gonna be a bathroom around here you know
like okay this is not our typical
situation but we had about a week where
we got to to sit and go through the
script and comb through and see where
see where those moments are that needed
to be heightened a little bit or you
know characters and tensions and things
like that and personally for me you know
this guy is Patrick's trying to live out
this this war fantasy and like a lot of
little boys it's fun to get around and
you know shoot some guns and get bad
guys but of course the the fantasy isn't
always what you think it's going to be
in the end and the island is is twisting
and giving you what you really need so
that the the story unfolds and allows
the character to unfold as well and so
it was really this this discovery every
day on set it was like where's where's
this guy going to go how is he gonna
feel in this very real situation that
happens to be taking place on this
fantastical island that was a beautiful
answer and I'm sorry to do this but
piggybacking off of what you just said
what is one what is one thing what is
one thing on set that you're used to
having that because you shot in Fiji you
didn't have this time around bathrooms
that freaks me out
when I got back to LA I in my head I
just was like oh I'll just I'm at the
bank I'll just go to the bathroom like
you know not in a bathroom just you know
in the alleyway I'd like that's gross
but in like in my head I got so used to
being being in the middle of a forest
and having to do what you have to do
what you know no just getting back to LA
and getting back to city life we hiked
to set you know you were at the banks if
you like did you get changed for a
twenty and use the one no but you just
you you get back to city life and I
definitely had to acclimate to it
because it becomes normal to hike to set
you know up a mountain for an hour and
this set is just gonna be it's just
there and then you you set up on a
mountain and you're gonna be there for
12 hours and you just gotta got to do
what you got to do I got really sick and
we were we were we were out of we were
at a place where you don't want to be
sick and in in between yeah and then in
between takes it was truly just yakking
up and then yelling over to Geoff going
yep okay good to go roll was it because
of something you ate or was like
seasickness on the cruise ship ever an
issue no it was a meal baby octopus oh
you were serious don't eat octopus there
okay all right I'm gonna put that in my
back pocket and not forget it I think
the variety and the convenience like
there's no over an island you just gotta
walk to like wherever you know and and a
variety of things like there's there's
one coffee shop there is one restaurant
and there's one you know so coming back
like I was just like oh man
oh man there's Thai food I forgot about
there was like you know Chinese food in
this place the variety and the luxury of
this choices
yeah yeah oh yeah this animals the bat
looked like it needed some help there we
went we were on the boat and this bat
was so we're traveling and this bat was
really it was raining and the bat was
like really trying hard to get through
the pouring rain and I just pointed out
and I go look at the bat and it came
straight at me
landed on my arm and then I'm holding it
like this it's on my finger and then we
tried to get a box to put the bat inside
and then it crawled up on my shoulders
very cute until well if got freaked out
by the box and then scratched me and now
I've got a great new career I'm the kind
of person that would go up to a snarling
dog and try to pet it so I get it it's
okay happens to the best of us needed
some help and then I put him on a
broomstick and he dried off and he was
gone in the morning and I don't have
rabies all right I don't think so as we
wind down here I have a feeling you guys
have already been asked this a million
times like what's your fantasy so I'm
trying to like break it down into some
fun categories here so give me a look
here to like raise your hand if one of
these is kind of original alright so
rapid-fire fantasies right now what is
your fantasy meal it didn't have to be
your last one that could be the answer
to both scenarios oh yeah yeah me and
also just hang on Tokyo and it was some
amazing food with soba for New Year
yeah favorite thing I had in Japan is
this thing called kyokotsu it's a piece
of Wagyu steak and they lightly fry with
breading outside and then they come and
cut the steak right but the steak
insides still rare and they bring a hot
stone for you on candlelight and you
grill the steak right in front of you in
Japan that is that is a fantasy meal I
would love to eat that oh go back to
Japan for that oh that is good too
Japanese Street food pancake that you
grill right in front of you and then it
has tons of green onions and this crema
that goes oh my god yeah my last meal my
last meal and Fiji was amazing it was
Lobster Ramon a sauce and the lobster
over there is a green spine lobster it's
just different than the Maine lobster
yeah it's green it's like spiny and they
chop up the lobster they put like butter
and coconut in it and it's so good it's
that could be a fantasy meal if we get a
sequel you should be like hosting a Food
Show or something I'm ready for it I'm
ready for it all right I'm into it I
your fantasy do-over anything in your
life if you got the chance to do it over
whoo
I woulda went to prom I guess ok
interview so I wouldn't have gone to so
many problems any more do-overs you can
opt out I mean mine I can't really say
yeah ok keep it to yourself ok the heavy
question actually french fries and ranch
dressing
yeah your do-over is not picking to have
that for breakfast morning that's a fair
one alright if you had your fantasy role
in a movie what would it be JD and
Fantasy Island mine is also JD in
fantasy that's I mean that's still a
fantasy answer I like that I've been
trying to play Mickey Mantle for years
my dad was in a movie called Escape from
New York and I had an actor yes I know
he played Romero and I would want to
play Romero I would love to play Kurt
Russell in that movie oh I got one a
baby and Dirty Dancing but they already
did a remake I did and they did it was
it was they did the live one
[Music]
Never Say Never we bring things back all
the time Jeff Wadlow Jeff all right all
right one last one just for fun your
fantasy day off what are you doing we
had some great day off life was with
Ryan Hansen and Austin we were living on
the cruise ship when we were was it a
cruise ship that's extreme we were on a
big boat the day off and we took these
kayaks out the three of us
I was so sunburned and my back was so
sore but we we got lost we got lost we
explored and with this village and that
people were so great there that's the
way to grow up in a German woman who was
who has a scuba diving school there on
this little like you would never know
that it's there there were lots of
magical things like that hiking to that
waterfall that was unbelievable up there
so usually on film sets the producers
and writers are like okay you guys can't
do X Y & Z you have to stay safe you
have to make sure that like we get
through the shoot but the producers and
and jeff wadlow we we all went waterfall
hiking and they allowed us to jump from
a waterfall which now looking back was
probably not very safe but it was not
more than 70 feet down we definitely
wouldn't do that
just like for the first time when you
got someone who just went bungee jumping
so tell me where that waterfall is and I
will go yeah
it's never weeds somewhere in Fiji it
was amazing before I let you guys go I
have a couple non-fantasy island
questions Michael I'm just gonna get
this out of the way because you know
where this is going
any chance we are gonna have you on set
working on another ant-man movie by the
end of this year no idea I have no idea
but even if I did know I couldn't tell
you but it's I think it's a year away
before production even starts so like
anything can happen the other one I
didn't really know I was gonna be in
until late late in the game so I don't
know you never know hurry up I'm a very
impatient person here Ryan
admittedly someone passed me this
question because I have not caught up on
Veronica Mars but watch and I didn't
want to [ __ ] you right now what are
your thoughts on where the show wrapped
up Wow well I do know that fans had a
very hard time with it
but I feel like that's the way the show
was kind of heading and it needed to
kind of grow up and do all that kind of
stuff my character would will never grow
up so I hope we get to keep doing it and
I get to be dick Austin my last one is
for you right now amazing stories is
hands-down one of my most anticipated
things on Apple TV right now
tell us anything about your experience
working on that anything about that
process or that story that really
surprised you what do we have to look
forward to well getting to reunite with
Steven Spielberg as
some hack director don't worry not the
the process is unreal you you have the
abilities in the to explore the depths
of a character that is living I don't
know what I'm allowed to say right now
he's from another time I can say that
much and it's very much like one of my
favorite shows quantum leap
so getting to to leap into that world a
little bit okay trying to be vague
Atlanta's beautiful a lot of great food
down there mark my lot our director is a
fantastic and not that I'm trying to get
into succession the next season or
anything like that but I think everybody
trying to get into suppression yeah
right I don't blame them yeah yeah okay
I don't know what I'm about to say job
well job well done you made me a little
more excited so cool yeah thank you guys
really good thank you guys so much for
your time today congratulations
everybody Fantasy Island hits theaters
on Valentine's Day
check it out like and share this
interview before you leave and we will
see you soon with more exclusive
Collider interviews